listen to your customers um you know  it's really important to find out what  your customers want  apis kpis kpis if you hit these numbers  each results will come  and that was driven into me so much  listen to people that have done it  before  and have been successful in your space  that you  to excel in and then be adaptable enough  to implement that  and i've got to check yourself sometimes  say all right i need to like take a step  back here  um so you know it's definitely something  you know i'm still still working on  taking a day working remotely and being  like right  i need some good and disconnected i  think those things are quite important  um from a self-reflection perspective  i think i was always pretty kind of  bullish about my own career and kind of  always  had my hand in the air you know i i sort  of knew that like  you know i would eventually maybe grow  out of uk  recruitment